good morning i'm kimberly god the
administrator for of deters employment
security division
this press briefing is held to provide
general information regarding leader esd
programs and processes
and is not specific to any one claim
please note that our press conference
process has changed as indicated in the
media advisory
we now are asking the media to provide
questions to dieter media
by wednesday each week so that we can
incorporate the information in our break
fees
as a reminder viewer cannot comment on
on
any current litigation with me today is
states chief economist dave schmidt he
will be providing
us the updated unemployment insurance
and pandemic unemployment assistance
data
thank you administrator god
standard unemployment insurance is for
nevadans who have lost their jobs
through no fault of their own
these people are these are people whose
employer pays taxes into the
unemployment insurance program through
the state's trust fund
and who both earned enough wages and
worked enough hours to be eligible for
those benefits
can we please put up the pie chart
as of july 18 2020 uh 590
92 700 total claims have been filed for
standard unemployment insurance
on the uinv site this number includes
both new claims
and reopened claims that have
intervening employment
also known as additional claims 571 048
of those claims have been filed
since march 14th of those eligible
filers who filed weekly claims for
in the week ending uh july 11th
uh 227 thousand two hundred and twenty
nine
or ninety percent of uh eligible claims
for that week were successfully paid
uh the number of weekly claims did
decline slightly from the prior week uh
was down by about five thousand
twelve thousand and 175 people filed for
benefits but were unemployed
employed and not eligible because they
had earnings for that week
that exceeded their weekly benefit
amount uh that's down slightly compared
to last week
1998 people had insufficient hours
and or wages to qualify for ui benefits
uh down by about 1 000 over the week
43 284 people did not file a claim for
the week
that's up slightly from last week and
has largely been steady over
the previous two months these are people
who started but
did not finish their weekly claim uh
never started their weekly claim
or reported to us that they were not
going to file a claim for the week
federal law does require that filers
file weekly claims
in order to receive payment uh finally
there were 23
411 other unp paid claims which was up
by about 6 000 from last week
these are filers whose claims are being
held because federal and state law
required deter to adjudicate their
claims
this number also includes claims that
have been identified as fraud
you can take the pie chart down pua is
pandemic unemployment assistance
and it's for those individuals
classified as contract 1099 and gig
workers
as well as other workers not covered
under traditional unemployment insurance
including people who have exhausted
their ui benefits
and all extended ui benefits
people still must be unemployed
underemployed unable to work or
unavailable for work
in a particular week due to covet 19.
to date nevada has taken uh 3149
uh pua initial claims uh as of july 20th
uh 300 873 of those have a weekly claim
filed or about 88 percent as of this
morning
121 980 claims have been paid
uh a total of uh over 1.3 billion
dollars
uh including both pua funds and fpuc
funds related to those pua claims
can we put up the table please
compared to nevada's estimated 82 000
self-employed workers
nevada has paid out over five thousand
one hundred dollars per self-employed
worker in regular pua benefits alone
uh that is the eighth highest level
among all states
uh by this measure and is uh includes
data through july 21st
uh you can take the table down
as of july 22nd uh dieter has paid out
nearly 5.4 billion dollars across all ui
and cares act
programs since the start of the pandemic
for comparison uh this exceeds the total
benefits paid out across both
unemployment insurance and all federal
extended benefits programs
uh in 2009 2010
and 2011 combined
uh with state unemployment benefits
remaining high uh the unemployment trust
fund continues to be drawn down
as of july 18th uh the trust fund
balance was uh 656.7 million dollars
which represents 5.8 weeks of benefit
benefit payments at current levels
uh in the event that the trust fund is
exhausted
the state would continue to pay
unemployment benefits
under the provisions of title 12 of the
social security act
uh and there will be no effect on
benefit payments uh just repeat
uh there will be no impact on benefit
payments
for unemployment insurance uh for those
eligible filers as a result of the
trust fund's decline
i we want to continue to remind
claimants in both ui and pua
that federal law requires you that you
must file a claim
every week in order to receive payment
for that week
many eligible claimants in both ui and
pua have not filed weekly claims and
therefore cannot be paid
with that will turn it back to
administrator gotham
thank you dave
um updates regarding quarter change um
this will
occur the first week in july and
requires states to check for new
and additional traditional ui
eligibility
peuc and seb or extended benefits
eligibility for the cares act and dol
guidance the coordination of programs
means that if you have traditional ui
or pandemic extended unemployment
eligibility or state extended benefit
eligibility you are required to file
for those benefits if you are eligible
before becoming eligible for pua
benefits pua filers receiving messaging
on their claim
indicating this new program eligibility
and traditional ui
peuc or seb should file their claim at
uinb.gov
using the claim itself portal
please go to employee to determine if
your claim reflects
this new eligibility please also visit
our website
dieter.nv.gov for further details
information and guidance
updates regarding um the federal
pandemic unemployment compensation
ending this week currently the carers
act federal pandemic unemployment
compensation
also known as fpec dollars commonly
referred to as the traditional 600
dollars added eligibility for ui
sunsets this saturday july 25th
this means that starting for the week
beginning sunday july 26th
filers are scheduled to receive their
calculated weekly benefit amount going
forward
dieter has been in communications with
the department of labor governor's
office and
federal delegates and we currently have
no updated information
on any extensions at this time filers
who are
eligible during the period that f-puck
was available
will still be able to receive f-puc
benefits for all eligible weeks
please watch for additional updates on
our website and dieter.nv.gov
as this information may change with the
pending legislation being considered by
congress
questions about pua function system
functionality
we have received questions for filers
regarding why it takes a number of days
or dates change
to receive payments on pua benefits
once it is reflected in the system that
the payments have issued
this is due to process steps required to
review payments to ensure
accurate disbursement of funds we are
aware that this is frustrating for
filers as you wait for these funds to
become available
we continue to work with our vendor to
automate this process and make it more
efficient
we also received inquiries from ui and
pua filers regarding decline
transactions for their ui and
pua banking accounts cards if you have
specific transactions declined
please check with your banking
institution for details
for filers that receive notice that an
account has been suspended or frozen
please call the ui call center or the
pool call center for further
instructions
you will have to provide identity
information so be prepared with this
information
requests for information regarding
overpayments
ui filers advised of an overpayment of
benefits must contact our call center
for updated information on ways to pay
back this money
for filers and current weekly filing
status you may see an offset
of continu current and future weeks of
benefits
in accordance with ui law and guidance
updates regarding pua appeals we
continue to receive questions regarding
appeals functionality
this functionality is operational whoa
filers are able to file an appeal
request through employee nv
filers wishing to file an appeal may do
so at employee through your account
portal
appeals requests for previously issued
eligibility determinations
will be honored for 30 calendar days
from july 18th
you may also contact the call center for
further instructions on how to file your
appeal
filers will need to watch for
communication in their portal in august
after filing their appeals request
information about access to the call
centers
dieter continues to work for ways to
provide additional resources to address
every claim
we continue to work with our call center
staff to update processes
and provide customer service feedback to
the best to best serve the data filers
we recommend choosing our offered
callback features to minimize time
waiting on the phone we continue to work
with the governor's office and our
legislators
and our federal delegations on funding
and staffing resources to provide and
expand service delivery for every
nevadan
deter is also experiencing difficulties
contacting filers as part of the
adjudication process
our staff may be calling you from the
following phone numbers
so please work with your carriers to
unblock these numbers
775-687-7101
702-486 is
and 702-486-3387
please ensure that you enable these
numbers with your mobile or telephone
carrier so you don't miss our calls
we will provide those phone numbers
again after the press briefing
additional additionally many employers
are seeking filers
who may be seeking job placement
assistance our job
is remain closed for the in-person
assistance
however our virtual job placement
services are available at employment
please visit employee nb for up-to-date
job placement opportunities
we've received a lot a number of
questions about system
security and fraud we strongly advise
nevadans use guidance from dieter as a
trusted source of information
there is no cost to file a claim online
and persons offering to complete or
assist with claims for fees
or to access your personal information
is not authorized by dieter
dieter has heard from many businesses
and citizens that may have had their
personal identifying information
accessed without their consent and used
for
filing for fraudulent claims this is not
a result of
any known data breach within dieter
deter actively monitors its systems
and works with reputable companies and
its vendors to ensure that all data is
maintained securely
nevada is actively working with law
enforcement entities and the department
of labor to detect
prevent and address fraud this includes
participation by dieter
as a member of the attorney general's
coven 19 fraud task force
if you believe that a claim has been
filed fraudulently using your
information
or you know somebody is committing fraud
the quickest way to report this
information
is three ways through deters updated
online fraud form at deter.nb.gov
select fraud reporting form under quick
links
or through the fbi's internet crime
complaint center
known as ic3 at www.ic3.gov
employers needing to report fraudulent
filings can respond to filing notices
indicating they believe the claim is
fraudulent
note the action to take action taken to
resolve these reports
may or may not include contact from our
office
tips on how to protect your personal
information can be found on our
website bulletin board dieter.nv.gov
excuse me note that unemployment fraud
is considered a felony under nevada
revised statute
nevada will be following fraudulent
claims up to and including prosecution
and other civil remedies afforded under
law we will be limiting further
information related to any
investigations and will not be sharing
details to protect the case integrity
thank you and we will look forward to
speaking with you again next friday with
additional updates and information
this concludes our remarks for today's
briefing